par c'était un voyage extraordinaire que
d'aller à la rencontre de cette tribu de
femmes merci qui vit dans le sud ouest
de l'ethiopie
malheureusement bon au cours des
conversations de sont assez limitées
parce que la langue est une barrière en
soi très clairement mais j'ai fini par
comprendre au cours de ma visite en
voyant des kalachnikovs dans les luttes
le jeu demander pourquoi qu'est ce que
c'était ça et on va se contente que
c'était là le but de défendre
éventuellement parce que les chinois
sont en train de partir barrage à la
demande du gouvernement éthiopien et
bien évidemment ils vont se faire une
ondée leur région la région de l'omo
qu'on appelle et c'est là le jardin de
l'ethiopie c'est là où on s'est pris
plein de choses la mort aigles le maïs
le sorgho tout ça et là bas y aura plus
rien tout ça pour le profit de dizaines
de multinationales n'entend plus les
liens s'étaient auto iv a pu finalement
l'union européenne a décidé de mettre
assez de pression sur cette entreprise
italienne de se sortir de ce dossier la
mairesse que le gouvernement était
surtout n'importe qui en face aux
chinois qu'ils ont acceptée or ils font
pire chez eux alors ils vont pas se
laisser déranger par quelques tribus et
alicia keys ou alors ça m'a fait
beaucoup beaucoup de tm2 savoir qu' on a
les rats ainsi l'or en fait chez nous je
suis un gros pot s'inquiéter je n'ai pas
pu vraiment communiquer mais par les
gestes pour les sourires avez vous
développé une intimité avec ces femmes
là j'imagine pas ce que peut prendre la
photo comme ça d'une personne sans
qu'elles se mettent à nu un peu et
c'était la journée du marché et comme on
naît avec
et là on s'est mis à l'abri parce que
l'oeuvre hommage à tomber comme des
clous et un moment donné il ya des
femmes des murs si ce sont celles qui
portent ces grands plateaux la bio anti
recul dans la lèvre serviable et convenu
se mettent aussi à l'abri sous le petit
chapiteau petit café et l'avait regardé
comme un peu comme des chiens de faïence
de part et d'autre et laure bonvin voix
tg un bracelet moi je vois qu elle al un
bracelet et ce alors là on commence à
faire des échanges
l'antonov biden et moi qu'on a des
caméras mandat a prêté les caméras bon
jeu long on leur demande comment
utiliser prenez photos de nounous à
l'inversé on prend des photos d'elle un
but qui nous accompagnait à rester alors
demandé si on pouvait aller les visiter
à madame ans dans leurs villages
respectifs
alors elles ont accepté et puis le
lendemain on s'est rendu au village
alors leur bon on s'invite ont pédalé eu
débat c'est comme ça quand je suis dans
ma cave elle est qualifiée comme mais on
a eu accès au plein sens où au gramme à
mainxe en 2d qui ont des cathares à
coups qui ont l'âge cassez qui sont
assis par terre et qui n avait pas eu la
possibilité de venir nous rencontrer
alors restez séjour extra plat et fatma
l'écossais à tout le monde
est-ce que vous connaissiez un peu le
passé l'esclavagisme qu'ont vécu ces
femmes là bas pendant des années
lorsqu'elle est le commerce triangulaire
est ce que il y a deux théories il est
malade très officieux là dessus mais bon
on s'était dit ce que les femmes mûres y
passer plateau à la demande de leurs
hommes pour les alésiens par peur
qu'elle se fasse prendre comme esclaves
pour aller rejoindre hebdo qui étaient
tous bénins ouaya alors ceci est une
théorie et un autre théorie qui dit que
c'est pour s'embellir et personnes âgées
c'est pas cool et embêtant mais ça
pourrait être une possibilité
l'ethiopie a toujours été assez
réfractaire à tout collé
al ismaily l'ont ils sont battus de ses
fans il ya jamais eu vraiment personne
qui est venu les colonisés alors ça ça
m'étonnerait peu mais c'est toujours une
possibilité
vous parlez ici vraiment d'un peuple
vous le décrivez est vraiment des gens
indépendants
par exemple au niveau de l'alimentation
ce qu'on a découvert nous sur le plateau
à montréal le bio ben euh ça fait
longtemps qu'il le pratique depuis des
quelques centaines d'années
c'est encore là c'est encore présents
c'est un cette fermeture qui a fait qu
ils ont pas été sollicité par alors et
comme il n'y a pas une grosse population
de ce côté là bas sont de moindre
intérêt par contre on card stud burkina
faso anneaux fait les frais g
non effectivement il c'est un top tu
manges grano au maximum et à aucune
chaîne de fast food à l'américaine qui
est sur place en a copié un peu des
idées de sable parce que c'est quand
même le berceau du café mais ça reste
que c'est des investissements étrangers
qui ont fait allégeance alimente très
très bien mais il faut intention
évidemment la viande de ce poids la
surabondance beaucoup beaucoup de grupo
de boeuf tout ça mais ils font attention
beaucoup des places hausse avec un taux
10 ans pour donner du goût mais les y
alignera aussi qu'il prend beaucoup de
place
taku sont plus mises à mort van de putte
un peu mois lui qui goûta plus le vin
merci c'est très simple
beaucoup beaucoup de céréales de fruits
de mer est une source de vitamine c est
incroyable pour eux enfin annoncé un
petit mot face à bien des égards et au
niveau du coton si les produits
d'exportation importante canton qui est
fait avec des couleurs végétales
on se croirait ici au pays des
amérindiens du dakota du nord a
pratiquement ouidah certains des dessins
aussi des matisse qu'ils emploient c'est
assez simple le coton c'est vrai que
matière première qui est trés important
pour
copie à la sardine est vrai qu'il est
plus fin qui ressemble plus à ce qu'on
retrouve aux indes donc plus facilement
portable pour des nord américains comme
nous l'a convié choses un peu plus
soyeuse l'or autour du cou les écharpes
et tout ça alors et on porte encore
beaucoup beaucoup le le costume
traditionnel ici or la robe blanche de
coton et pour toutes les occasions que
ce soit pour aller à la messe que ce
soit baptême ou une occasion politique
comporte toujours ses vêtements qui est
en coton la main avec multiples broderie
aussi qui équivaut dessus la messe était
très jeune
bon là vous êtes en train de me donner
le goût d'aller faire du magasinage pour
utiliser cette expression canadienne
mais si vous deviez aller magasiner ya
beaucoup de choses à faire en ethiopie
samaa et année au niveau du tourisme
car qu'on a évité des tribus y en avait
au moins piste juste dans la région où
j'étais à jean ita ensuite si on va plus
vers le nord évidemment là il ya toutes
les églises orthodoxes qui datent du
3ème siècle après six ans est ce
vraiment intéressante à déguster moi je
me promets que c'est mon prochain tour
quand je serai en ethiopie et a
évidemment le tracking il ya de la
marche à faire en montagne apparemment
que c'est incroyable dans beaucoup sud
animaux et deviennent alors pays à
l'ordre
non c'est un pays extrêmement
intéressant monf devriez devenir
ambassadrice du commerce pour l'ethiopie
ils ont beaucoup pas nadal en 12 années
et ils sont 1 tradition ça bouge
beaucoup moins vite que ce qui s'est
passé en chine inquiète à moins de 20
ans tout était réglé mais là-bas la
création est très très lourde en corse
et ses traits laurencin encore beaucoup
beaucoup d' ingérence le départ du
gouvernement mais elles servent pas
évolué
arrêtons là sinon ils vous laisseront
pas rentrer la prochaine fois
c'est de bonne guerre comme on dit